їхнє обличчя закриті балаклавами на очах
темні окуляри тільки так їх можуть
показати пресі це українські танкісти
яких готують в Німеччині воювати на
леопардах в Україні
у вас є відчуття страху
жодного і хабика звертатися
лише німецькою мовою і через перекладача
запитувати щось навіть українською не
дозволяється такі вимоги бундесферу на
полігоні у федеральній землі саксонія
Анхель що на сході Німеччини за дві
години їзди від Берліна керувати
німецькими танками леопард 1 навчають
інструктори з Німеччини Данії та
Нідерландів танки дуже добрі є в нього
декілька значних переваг над російськими
танками та 72
ну з тих що я можу назвати це швидкість
та маневраність леопардів і їхня точна
гармата інші не буде я називати щоб не
полегшувати роботу противнику німецький
уряд оголосив про рішення постачати
Україні танки леопард понад півроку тому
на початку лютого у Німеччині прийшли
Навчання вже близько шести тисяч
українських військових а до кінця цього
року їхня кількість перевищать позначку
10 тисяч особливо акцент на танкістах
[музика]
це у нас вже перевірена програма для
такого специфічного навчання вони
приходять сюди з нульовими знаннями про
цю конкретну бойову машину незалежно від
того пройшли вони попередню підготовку
на іншому танку чи ні вони практично
знайомляться із цією машиною з усіма її
особливостями та функціями насправді цей
графік ми на цей момент не дуже змінили
тому що він вже добре зарекомендував
себе в минулому на початку перших етапів
навчання ми проаналізували що добре а що
не дуже на цей момент ми маємо
перевірений спосіб навчання і ви бачили
що вони тут засвоїли за короткий
проміжок часу і продемонстрували гідну
стрільбу
українські штанкісти небагатослівні Вони
дякували німецькій владі за допомогу
уникали зайвих деталей про особливості
підготовки натомість жартували як краще
в Германії приїхав просто на екскурсію
на відпочи ніж на такі навчання Євген зі
Сходу України йому 32 роки вдома його
чекає дружина і шестирічний син до війни
він працював диспетчером електромереж а
після початку повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії в Україну
перекваліфікувався на танкіста по-перше
є величезна мотивація
мотиваціон хочеться по скоріше перемогти
шнеля зігин а інше Ну ми ж навчались на
своїх танках танки є танк трішки
відрізняється Але
як я б сказав навіть не леопардові
навчатися простіше ніж на наших танках
інструктори відзначають високу мотивацію
з якою українці освоюють німецьку
техніку кажуть що військові ЗСУ
навчаються значно швидше за європейців
курс навчання розрахований на 6 тижнів
заняття відбувається 6 днів на тиждень
хотів би наголосити на тому що ми бачимо
насамперед Це неймовірно виняткова
мотивація оперативно готовність і жага
українських солдатів до навчання це
насправді дуже надихає і мотивує
військових інструкторів чи то німецьких
чи як у цьому випадку данських та
голландських інструкторів
і Вони намагаються дати за такий
короткий час якомога більше знань
необхідних для того щоб упоратися з цим
жахливим випробуванням необхідністю йти
на війну
ці маневри зі стрільбою були завершенням
навчання чергової групи українських
Танкістів 17 цілей вони вразили 15
причому з першого разу наступного тижня
вони повертаються в Україну і на їхнє
місце приїжджають нові українські
військові впевнені отримані в Німеччині
навички допоможуть їм в контрнаступі